♪♪
What piece of advice
would you give
to people staying
in a hotel room?
-Don't.
-Just don't go to hotels?
I would sleep
in my car.
I need
to hear the details.
What's, like, the grossest thing
you've ever found?
Probably is
the double-sided dildo.
The one?
You won't forget it.
Guy says, "Come on in."
And when I come in,
he's handcuffed
and duct-taped
to a stripper pole.
So what did he say?
He was like, "What I want you
to do is pick up that flogger
over there and hit me
a couple of times."
-Did you do it?!
-Yep.
For an extra $200,
I could end my afternoon
and go to McDonald's.
Yep.
What did you get
at McDonald's for $200?
That's not important.
-That's a nice day.
-Right?
So, that's been the worst --
handprint shit stains?
There was massive
anal leakage.
So you've seen different levels
of it, and this was the most?
It looked like a crime scene
but only with shit.
Oh no. Like someone had killed
someone made of shit.
Based on your expertise,
can you tell me
where most people jizz?
All over the pillows.
It's all over the sheets,
the pillows.
You could take
the pillow sheets off.
It's on the pillow.
-Pillows.
-I'm hearing this.
On all surfaces,
especially phone
and the remote control.
Lampshades.
Don't touch the lights.
The switch for the lamp.
The toilet.
Don't step on the bathroom
floor with no shoes.
Shower handles.
Don't touch the doorknob.
And the doorknob
to the bathroom.
And the door.
Don't touch anything
near the door.
So, how do I get in?
Check your sheets.
I don't even know
why I'm sitting on it.
Yeah, let's get
this out of here.
You want to peel down
the top layer
and then even
the second layer.
Those things
do not get washed,
and that's where
most of the jizz is.
Now, how gross is this
that we're sitting on now?
It's pretty gross.
Why are they doing it
on the side of the bed?
Because they pull out
and -- sskkt!
It could be lurking
almost anywhere.
And God only knows
what's on the carpet.
I really feel like we should
let the people know
and we should do
something about this.
Announcer: The following message
has been paid for
by the Janitorial Institute
of Safety Mandates.
Hotel rooms were built for sex
and self-gratification.
Big beds, Wi-Fi,
the "do not disturb" sign,
unlimited towels, and,
best of all, no clean-up --
for you.
But for these ladies,
it's another story.
When you check out,
you're leaving more
than your Galaxy Note 5
charger behind.
You're leaving a crusty trail
of evidence that you're gross.
Your room is not your sock.
This is your sock.
So if you shot it on the floor,
leave a $20 by the door.
If you make a mess
when you mount her,
leave some cash on the counter.
And if you're gonna make
a puddle,
leave a tip before you board
the airport shuttle.
This -- that one's not great.
Look, no one's telling you
not to pull out
and spray it around
like a sprinkler if that's how
you want to celebrate
your sister's wedding.
And ladies- no one's saying
don't jam some sheets all up
in there after you've had sex.
So you don't have to go to bed
with a soggy vag.
It would be nice if you used a
tissue.
Yeah- but it's like- they're in
the bathroom and it's far,
and I'm tired.
(whispering)
It's fine, just use the sheet.
So the next time you're about
to jizz all over a hotel room,
think about these women.
Uh, like, that...
Shhh.
Together:
Stop jizzing on everything.
Everything.